of course they're missing him and some
people are missing him even more than
brian stelter you know brian stelter
basically saying no you know it's like
he got dumped by his girlfriend he said
no i don't
i never even think about her what are
you talking about no not
i don't think i don't lay awake at night
every night thinking about her well some
people miss
trump even more than brian stelter does
namely the
the majority leader of the us senate
chuck schumer who who made a little
freudian slip on the floor last week
it will be a fair trial but make no
mistake
there will be a trial and when that
trial ends senators will have to decide
if they believe donald john donald john
trump
incited the erection insurrection
against the united states oh he did
chuck he truer words have never been
spoken certainly have never been spoken
spoken by chuck schumer if donald trump
incited anything he incited that
among democrats among the press
they had very complex ideas about it it
was a little bit of a
sado masochistic kind of situation
but but he did incite that among them
and among among many other people that
is a freudian slip
where of course you say one thing but
mean your mother
and uh chuck schumer is is not alone in
his party they're going to drag this out
we're going to be talking about
trump through february through
mid-february probably
they're going to impeach him and you
know what they're going to do once they
acquit him
they're probably just going to impeach
him again
i'm not predicting that will happen at
this point i wouldn't be surprised
they have to do it and it's
in a way it's sort of sad because
the reason that trump was so interesting
is not just his personality which of
course is very eccentric
and he's a tv star and he's been a pop
culture figure for
40 years so obviously that's part of the
reason we're all fascinated by him
but another reason we're fascinated by
him is that he offered something
different
than the status quo which which had been
offered by
certainly by the progressive left by the
democrats for many decades but even by
the republicans
who were just sort of the the flip side
to that progressive coin
they were sort of the court gestures in
the kingdom of liberalism
they all you know all republicans could
really offer would be to cut taxes
but on on the substantive cultural
issues they basically just rolled over
was all kind of the same
then trump offers something different
now what trump was offering protect our
borders
don't let grown men go into the little
girls room at the public pool
uh support jobs defend a foreign policy
that that
puts america first before other
countries these kind of things
very very basic defend our constitution
right
totally common sense what the left is
offering
is not at all common sense it's
absolutely radical censor half of the
country
force little girls to change with grown
men
redefine bedrock social institutions
radically redistribute wealth institute
a new racial caste system
give a lot of our money to foreign
powers and give a lot of our sovereignty
over to them as well
all that sort of stuff slaughter a
million babies a year all that kind of
stuff
completely radical stuff but because
it's been going on for so long we're
used to it we're used to it and that
seems like what is normal
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you